الله
لا اله الا الله
والنعم ونعنا
[Silence]
ب شخله يا
سلم ايديك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
‏have
to
any of any type of
those two principles are
the relativity ofliness yes some things
you
‏something is considered clean relative
to what it is right or where it is and
number two
yes that purifying is by any means as
long as it becomes removed that's what
important and we said that is because it
does not need an intention right so
number one relativity
‏number
by any as
any
way
here
اعلم شارعه يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى الذي
عرفنا كون هذه العين او متنجسه عرفنا
ايضا كيفيه تطهيرها
والواجب علينا اتباع قوله وامتثال امره
فما ورد فيه الغسل حتى لا يبقى منه لون
ولا ريح ولا طعم كان ذلك هو تطهيره وما
ورد فيه الصب
او الرش او الحت او المسح على الارض او
مجرد المشي في ارض طاهره كان ذلك هو
تطهيره واعلم ان الماء هو الاصل في تطهير
النجاسات لوصف الشارع له بقوله خلق الله
الماء طهورا فلا يعدل الى غيره الا اذا
ثبت ذلك عن الشارع والا فلا لانه عدول
عن المعلوم
كونه طهورا الى ما لم يعلم كونه طهورا
وذلك خروج عما تقتضيه المسالك الشرعيه
وهذا الكلام ماخوذ من كلام الشوكاني رحمه
الله في
السيل الجرار المتدفق على نزهه الازهار
اوكي
وهو تطهير جلد الميته بالدباغ
‏And that is
a hide will turn it from a dead hide
which is impure to a pure pie of lether
right this is called tanning and so that
is the method that we use to purify
a dead animal's hide so every dead
animal's hide that has been tanned
طاهر يقول المؤلف تطهير الاناء اذا ولغ
فيه الكلب
nextly
[Silence]
‏to
something a person eats from drinks from
it have to be specifically a cup no prop
uses the cup as example because that's
what is most likely a is going to drink
out of
يقول عن ابي هريره ان رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال طهور اناء احدكم اذا ولغ
فيه الكلب ان يغسله سبع مرات اولاهن
بالتراب
والحديث عند البخاري وابي داوود
اساسا يثرب
هريره
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
is
wased times the first of which using
dirt and we mention yesterday and before
that
does a person have to
‏would be acceptable
answer yes would be acceptable
because the second principle that we
mentioned is
by any me right so if a person to use so
back in the time of the propet صلى الله
عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
right we said that the dogs saliva and
the pig they are of the same level of
intensity with respect
‏with to
before we going to be important for us
to understand something about a
just we mention that cleanliness is
relative
also it's important for us to know that
a
filth is of different levels of
intensity
so there are three levels
‏number
in level of
and
these levels because of how we are to
how rigorous
a person is to clean them. ‏So the thing
that we are to clean the most is the
dogs and the pig the prophet
tells us to wash it seven times and to
use dirt right the second level which is
a medium level and that is most of the
types of filth so urine fees most types
of filth are of
نجاسه
بول الصبي
الذي لم ياكل الطعام بعد ما زال مازال
رضيعا ولم ياكل الطعام وكذلك المذي
المذي ايضا في هذه المرتبه
number
so number it is a bo number two it is
infant that is suckling he not eating
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
المذي
صلى الله عليه
‏it
is a person
all they have put on it don't have iting
it out was it is only a
in the Arabic language is to sprinkle
right this is
[Arabic recitation]
we took today isying
the hi of a deadal and that is by way of
tanning number two purifying
something from the saliva of a dog and
also
a pig and that is that is washed
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يفقهنا في ديننا وان يستعملنا ولا
يستبدلنا اللهم استعملنا ولا تستبدلنا
اللهم استعملنا قبل موتنا يا رب العالمين
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
صلاه العشاء
ان شاء الله صلاه العشاء
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]